hey 42 here just like the elusive Loch
Ness monster a white hole is an
interesting idea that has not yet been
proved to be real well there's no good
reason why it couldn't be real you see
white holes are highly speculative tales
told by astronomers to potentially
explain what's on the other side of a
black hole so what exactly is a white
hole and do they really exist let's find
out a white hole is the exact opposite
of a black hole a black hole sucks in
matter and no matter can escape it
whereas a white hole spews out matter
but matter cannot enter it most
physicists say that white holes are
extremely unlikely to be real and their
existence is in fact impossible but new
evidence suggests otherwise since the
two are so intrinsically linked to fully
understand what a white hole actually is
we first need to have a little chat
about black holes a black hole is formed
when a massive star runs out of fuel to
carry on the process of nuclear fusion
and so it collapses in on itself this is
known as a supernova then its
gravitational pull gets stronger and
stronger causing the collapse start to
collapse further and further in on
itself into a single point eventually it
reaches a point of infinite density
known as a gravitational singularity the
gravitational pull of a singularity is
so powerful that nothing can escape it
not even light and so we have a black
hole a black hole is completely non
visible because one's light enters a
singularities event horizon it can't
escape its gravitational pull so the
light never returns to our rivals but
that's about all that scientists truly
know about black holes okay they do know
a little bit more than I am generalizing
sorry Steve but my point is that we have
only scratched the surface of what a
black hole really is and how it behaves
and don't even get me started on what
happens when you enter a black hole and
importantly what's on the other side of
it literally no one knows that seriously
there are countless theories out there
of course some fear eyes are black holes
are portals to a parallel universe
or we say they lead to wormholes that
theoretically allow us to traverse
massive distances in space faster than
the speed of light but for a long time
the most universally accepted theory has
been that whatever enters a black hole
is trapped there for eternity like
placing something inside a locked room
then destroying the cave
scientists have a special name for
anything and everything that is sucked
up by a black hole from stars to radio
waves photons of light and even entire
solar systems scientists simply call it
information for decades many scientists
believe that when information is claimed
by a black hole it is lost forever but
there's an alternative theory which is
backed up by brand-new evidence that
suggests this information could possibly
be recovered this is where white holes
come you see there's a fundamental
problem we're suggesting that all
information that enters a black hole is
lost forever
both Albert Einstein and Isaac Newton
said matter cannot be created or
destroyed it can only change into other
forms now that's fine if the black hole
functions as a locked-room trapping the
information for eternity because nothing
will ever be destroyed however in 1975
Stephen Hawking came up with the widely
accepted idea of Hawking radiation which
states that black holes actually radiate
energy and even more incredibly he
demonstrated how black holes actually
evaporate over time they're not
permanent residents of space like we
previously thought so when a black hole
evaporates what happens to all the
matter that it has sucked up Hawking
radiation appears to contradict the idea
that matter can't be destroyed there has
been a ravenous debate raging on in the
physics community about this ever since
Stephen Hawking's revelation you know
how feisty those fists
can get a possible answer to this
dilemma is that black holes can actually
turn into so-called white holes when
this happens the newly born white hole
spews out all the information it's
sucked up during its previous life as a
black hole like opening a can of
miscellaneous space crap and shaking it
all over the damn place if this theory
is true then it once and for all settles
the debate over Hawking radiation and
the loss of matter inside black holes
because it means that matter isn't
actually lost when the black hole
evaporates it is instead recovered
albeit a considerably worse shape than
when it entered some people have even
taken the idea of white holes one step
further by theorizing that black holes
are actually joins to white holes via a
wormhole which is a shortcut through
space and if we were to enter a black
hole we could travel huge distances
through space at a rate considerably
faster than the speed of light not by
actually traveling faster than the speed
of light according to Einstein's theory
of special relativity that's impossible
but by simply taking a shortcut through
the universe by modifying the shape of
the space-time continuum there's all
kinds of extreme theories out there
often borrowed from science fiction
which states that these passages through
space-time would allow us to travel
through time but that's mostly just
speculation the general idea of the
white hole wormhole theory is that
anything which enters a black hole takes
a quick straw through the back alleys of
the universe before being ejected
violently out of a white hole somewhere
else in space or possibly in another
universe altogether some people even say
that the Big Bang itself was a white
hole which came into existence as a
result of a black hole forming in
another universe and expanding outwards
into a brand-new universe there's been a
lot of research into this theory and
it's not totally implausible if it were
to prove true it would mean that our
entire universe and everything we know
is inside a black hole
which is part of a much much larger
parent universe that's right you could
be living inside a black hole whatever
you may have heard or believed about
white holes there's no doubt that if
they do exist they offer some incredibly
exciting possibilities which leaves the
obvious question do they exist for a
long time the existence of white holes
has been vehemently opposed by many
figurative in the scientific community
recently however that all changed
observatories both here on earth and in
space are constantly monitoring for
strange things hitting us from far away
in space such as radio waves or gamma
rays in 2006 a gamma-ray burst was
observed that didn't fit of the
traditional parameters under which gamma
rays behaved it has an extraordinarily
long duration of 102 seconds which means
it had to have come from a supernova
explosion what's there are no known
supernovae that it could have come from
the scientists who discovered the gamma
ray burst actually said this is
brand-new territory we have no fear ease
to guidance so they basically said we
have no idea what the hell that was
let's put it in a box somewhere and
forget about it
which they pretty much did but five
years later it has been suggested that
the gamma ray burst in 2006 of unknown
origin could have actually come from a
white hole popping into existence for
102 seconds spewing out a whole load of
matter then disappearing the features of
the gamma ray burst perfectly aligned
with what we know about white holes and
how they behave this explanation to this
unusual gamma-ray event has not been
accepted by everyone well it's the
strongest evidence we have ever found
that supports the existence of the
mysterious interstellar Loch Ness
monsters that are white holes thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
[Music]
you